[Music]
these government troops are withdrawing
driven out by fighters of the Al
qaeda-affiliated Islamic state in Iraq
and the Levant or ISIL the group wants
to establish an Islamic state in Iraq
and Syria the two sides battle for days
over control over Mosul and its valuable
oil fields ISIL now holds large parts of
the city in the north of the country
thousands of residents have fled the
grip already controls much of Iraq's
Western Anbar province including the
city of Fallujah and the Syrian border
area and believed ISIL receives new
weapons supplies from there almost
400,000 people have fled fighting in
Anbar province seen here in the
provincial capital Ramadi government
troops have suffered repeated setbacks
in their efforts to take back control
Iraq's Shiite Prime Minister Nouri
al-maliki is struggling to hold on to
power recent elections left him short of
the majority needed to form a new
government Islamists are taking
advantage of the power vacuum the
violence between Sunnis and Shiites has
soared since the beginning of last year
and claimed thousands of lives
last weekend alone more than 100 people
were killed in a series of bombings